it's almost time the playstation 5 hits
us with its next generation goodness in
a matter of weeks
and to get you fully ready i've made a
list of 50 things you need to know
before your ps5 comes home with you
if you've pre-ordered this video will
give you a warm fuzzy feeling inside
as you wait for your new console to
arrive and if you're new here or you're
on the fence you'll see some cool tech
let's see how many of these 50 you
already know
let's get the basics out of the way the
playstation 5 is available in two
iterations one with a 4k blu-ray drive
and one without the digital version
here's the first thing of note
the ps5 is 99 backwards compatible with
your ps4 games it's great yeah
well if you have disc based games on
your ps4 and you plan to ditch that
console
you'll need to have the disk version of
the ps5 to carry on playing them next
gen
because once you go digital your disks
are useless
speaking of games at launch loads of
games will have free upgrades to ps5
to optimize and enhance your experience
so if you own any of these games
including fortnite assassin's creed
valhalla borderlands 3 destiny 2 do
maternal
the list goes on and on know that you'll
have a shiny new version on day one for
ps5
the upgrades you'll see can vary from
improved load times
updated visuals and higher quality
textures
and my personal favorite improved frame
rates for example
ghost of tsushima will run at 60 frames
per second
on the ps5 there are other games which
you'll need to be a bit careful around
for example call of duty black ops
you'll need to spend an extra 10
10 euros or 10 pounds to move your
experience from ps4 to ps5
pretty short move in my opinion later in
the ps5 cycle
free upgrades to other games will start
to pop up such as cyberpunk 2077
and gta online gta online is a bit
strange it's a free download but only
during its first three months on the
market on ps5 so be sure to download
that and rake in the savings
and to round out our luck on games look
at this behemoth
the playstation plus collection 18 of
the best playstation 4 games will be
available
on day one for all ps plus subscribers
who buy a ps5
18. i break them all down in this video
here but the ones which really blew my
mind were the god of war and days gone
and there's another 16 on top of that
all for free for the ps plus fam
let's break down the console next did
you see the tear down from playstation
man that was strangely satisfying here's
the main things of note there
it's thick and chunky like no other
the reason for this size is directly
linked to the ps4
and issues many of us had real talk
right now homies
how much of a jet engine did your ps4
sound like
it's not a great selling point is it
well this issue is being reversed to
become a key selling point instead
from audio tests from youtubers who
aren't me they say that the ps5
is virtually silent and remain that way
for their entire playtime
inside the ps5 you'll see the sheer size
of the heatsink and
fan damn that's thick the massive
heatsink acts like a
heat absorber to keep the processor
super chilled
all the way around the console are vents
to push and pull the air around to keep
things super cool too
and even dust has been thought about
with the ps5 and should keep dust at bay
let's see if that's still the same in 12
months though but right now this is
music to my ears
in fact there is more many people have
chosen the digital ps5 over the
based beast as that disk drive could be
loud
sony have once again decided to fight
this and encase the drive in a kind of
anti-vibration tech
with dual layered insulation which
hugely quietens the drive
again we shall see in november but if
this is true the ps5 will be the
quietest console you've ever
heard or not heard you know what i mean
and to finish this section on heat and
sound
check out the coolest thing you'll see
today the ps5 has a liquid metal cooling
mechanism
designed to keep your ps5 working like
it's day one
for years to come wow on the rear of the
console are two usb
ports you should be aware of as well as
the good old lan port and this one the
hdmi
output this is something i'd like to
break down further if i may
the ps5 supports hdmi 2.1
this is a step up from the previous
version which supports 48 gigabits per
second data transfer
don't worry i'll break it down hdmi 2.0
the one we
used to use on the ps4 had 18 gigabits
per second
so there's a huge difference there let's
not make this a tech talk though
the new cable and system means we can
output to our tvs and monitors at 4k
at get this 120 frames per second
and should that day ever come 8k
resolution at 60 frames per second
for those that understand color gamuts
hdmi 2.1 has bt
2020 don't worry i'm clueless too but in
layman's terms this means
a massive colour range in the new hdmi
cables
and this is also the reason why when you
walk into tech stores they always have a
colorful
bay or mountain scene on all the screens
to show you the full colour range of
that unit
so getting this back to ps5 in gaming
terms
expect miles morales to look super
colorful on the ps5
another great thing about hdmi 2.1 is
all
mode in which the delay or the latency
between your thumb sticks and the
character moving on screen
is super low and it's all automatically
done when you switch the ps5 on but
here's a huge caveat
this does mean to get the best out of
the system we'll need a tv or monitor
which supports hdmi 2.1 inputs
so these changes won't be with many of
us on day one for right now though in
this moment
it doesn't matter if you don't have a tv
which supports hdmi 2.1
you're good to go all the same just keep
going with the same tech maybe think
about upgrading later in the playstation
5's lifecycle
to get a little bit more out of your ps5
going back to frame rates if you're used
to 30 frames or even 60 frames per
second the move up to 120
is mind-blowing the smoother gameplay
will result in your improvement as a
gamer and less strain on your eyes
those extra frames make reacting in
competitive shooters easier too
as there's twice as much information to
see and react to
every second in terms of using 120
frames per second
i wouldn't expect many games to do this
past first person shooters
it may take a year into the ps5 cycle
for more games to utilize 120
frames more realistically 60 frames
should become the norm
this generation so the ps5 is designed
to stand up tall or lay down flat
and just like previous generations a
stand is required
but this time it comes with your
purchase no more shelling out another
twenty dollars for an official stand
like the ps4 a screw is needed when your
console is in vertical position which
means a screwdriver is needed too
if you prefer your console horizontal
the stand will need to be removed
and then clicked into place like this
also note there's a place to store your
screw
it's not a big deal it made me smile
next as you'd likely know the ps5 has a
solid-state drive with 825 gigabytes of
storage space
the killer about this ssd is the speed
it's a potential game changer for the
industry
as it diminishes load times greatly i
wonder what it will do with the initial
load time on gta online games like
spider-man in which loading was hidden
behind peter on the subway
well these will be removed completely
this tech is mind-blowing
some people were uncertain about the
size of the storage 825 gigabytes
and for those people who want more space
something of note
an expansion slot it's an m2 interface
with pcie 4.0 support
that means we can buy additional storage
compatible with the ps5
and keep even more games downloaded as
simple as that
another great thing of note is that
although sony will certify drives worthy
of use in the ps5
it will not close the market competitors
can and will create ssds
and the cost will drop over time as each
company undercuts the next
and ultimately the consumer wins and we
get cheaper tech
good times but right off the bat these
are going to be so expensive
so be very mindful of that and you
should also note your warranty is fully
protected when adding extra storage
if you want to know the exact moment
your warranty is void
it's when you take off these stickers so
don't do that
speaking of updated cables let's look at
the front of the console and there is a
high speed usb
port you'd expect there but below that
is the ps5
usb type c port this thing has crazy
fast speed exchanges
should you need to move videos or audio
or game saves to other devices
but the thing about the usbc is the
cable goes in either way around
so if like me you've ever failed to plug
in a usb cable and then
turned it round and failed again and
then rotated it around again and then it
finally goes in
yeah those days those days are numbered
oh and to confirm the two extra usb type
a ports on the back of the console
are super speed ones that's why they
have a blue inlay like this
and the standard one on the front
doesn't so if you aren't using usbc to
transfer data
ignore this one on the front and use the
two super speed ones on the back
and to finish this physical segment on
the console the face plates
did you see how easy they are removed
this indicates we are encouraged to do
this
and get inside our ps5 for the ssd
upgrades
but this also all but confirms the
return of customizable faceplates
we have the choice to stick with the og
white or purchase or customize our own
versions
and stand out from the crowd what
designs would you have on a custom
faceplate
there are some great concepts out there
already this is excitement
in the most non-gamer way possible love
it
next we have something you can't see
because it's audio
the ps5 is set to revolutionize 3d audio
in games
at present if you've ever had the
sensation of hearing an opponent in game
but you are unable to locate them due to
ineffective audio cues
on the ps5 3d audio has been a huge
point of interest
and from the feedback we've heard the
precision and fine-tuning of audio
bouncing off walls in games is
unprecedented on the ps5
our spatial awareness in video games is
getting an upgrade to mimic 360 degree
audio you get in high quality
cinemas i'll have to hear this to
believe this but the signs are good
next up we have trophies one of the most
addicting things about being a gamer
collecting trophies
and flexing on your friends the ps5 has
revamped this system and if you're on
ps4
it's already updated you can now check
yours right now and you'll find your
level has risen
i'm currently rank 409 i think which is
not too shabby i may say
the old system used 1-99 to define a
level and now that's changed to 1
to 999 with platinum trophies worth
even more and i have to admit seeing
that number makes me want to start
chasing trophies again
how do you feel about trophies right now
what level are you at
and finally the controller you can't
play a game without something to play
with
i've made a full breakdown of the 21
tiny changes i noticed when the dual
sense was revealed
but here's the most important things of
note now the new shape
following the work of sega atari
nintendo and xbox
sony have redesigned the controller for
comfort
so expect it to take a few days to get
used to the term dual sense refers to
touch
and audio gone are the old-school rumble
motors replaced with haptic tech
haptic feedback is the tension on items
we use in game
they will react in a more realistic way
for example a bulb being pulled back
will have the string resistance mimicked
on the controller
making it harder to push the button this
will feel different from say
shooting a pistol added realism and in
driving games
the soil the tarmac the track under your
wheels will feel drastically different
just like in real life the sound aspect
of the controller relates to the 3d
audio tech we've looked at earlier
but also note there is a near-field
inbuilt microphone in the controller
on the front is a light bar which
indicates what player you are in the
game
i like that it's a nice touch and look
on the underside of the controller
the grip bumps are playstation shaped
brilliant touch
and lastly every ps5 will come with
astros playroom a free game
installed in which you will learn
everything about the controller and its
abilities
first hand inside the ps5 which is
another amazing touch
you'll also find a museum in here
somewhere showing the history of
playstation
is anyone here from the 90s nope just me
okay i get it so there we have it 50
things you need to know about the
playstation 5.
hopefully there was something you didn't
know and i'm guessing it's the hdmi 2.1
bit
am i right anyway thank you for sticking
around for so long it's much appreciated
i'm adam from playstation grenade i
shall see you next time
[Music]
foreign